boss fights are almost becoming a relic
of the past with fewer and fewer games
featuring big bads but they're not gone
and forgotten yet this year had a few
awesome standout boss fights that
challenged you in new ways including the
final boss of wolfenstein which offered
up a nice surprise throwback for fans of
the series as well as the bevy of
tactics and planning that you'd have
needed to gather up in order to take out
the numerous bosses of transistor but
here are my five picks for best boss
fights of 2014.
a boss fight isn't necessarily good
because the boss is particularly hard or
that it has a sweet design it needs to
offer you something more than that
like i don't know for example respawning
all the major bosses of a region for an
all-out assault early on in divinity
original sin before your party is beefy
as [ __ ] you need to face off against
brachus rex that on its own would be
dealable but he's brought along the
poison laced ghoul that guards the
lighthouse the fiery twins by fire
joined and diederich the sword wielding
baron of bones they've all got lists of
strengths and vulnerabilities as long as
they're names so you need to be careful
about which attacks to use when and
where and try not to get hemmed in by
the lot of them on the plus side this
difficult level 9 fight prepares you
extremely well for the rest of the game
by demanding a mastery of the elemental
system by teaching you that fire
explodes poison oil costs slow and so on
destiny might seem like a contentious
choice but its first raid vault of glass
is surprisingly engaging the six-player
raid consists of three stages opening
the vault offing the templar and
launching an assault on the glass throne
in order to kill atheon the final boss
easy right no
not easy the raid is filled with a bunch
of game mechanics that were nowhere to
be seen in the main game new enemy types
puzzles to solve and an instance where
your party gets separated at random none
of this is ever explained and the first
group to finish the raid allegedly took
over 8 hours to work it out like any
good boss fight the vaulted glass is
particularly clever in the way that it
forces you to adapt and learn new
situations and really work as a team in
order to come out alive
it probably comes as no surprise that
being at a 2 is filled with epic bosses
the batshit crazy game is just
overflowing with larger-than-life foes
but here's some of the best even though
you'll probably just be using your
tried-and-true combos and witch-time
tactics to take out well everybody the
design and scope of these baddies is
insane there's towering infernal dragon
creatures who dwarf your leggy
protagonist mighty and well-equipped
angels as well as speedy enormous
spiders each fight ends in a unique
climax finishing move which really
cements its status as over the top it's
difficult to say whether bayonetta 2's
bosses are lovely or ludicrous in this
regard but whichever way you look at the
plethora of gargantuan villains they
certainly belong on this list
shovel knight is another game that is
just packed with awesome bosses but none
are more tough or fun than the final
boss the enchantress the awesome thing
about the face-off between shovel knight
and the enchantress is that you aren't
alone at this point in the game you've
rescued your beloved shield knight after
countless trials and he or she fights by
your side and acts as a necessary part
of this battle a feature that solidifies
how essential she is to your protagonist
in the narrative it's a tricky set of
three stages that involve dodging
fireballs and jumping off shield
knight's shield to get to higher ground
the battle is also incredibly worth it
for the payoff an unexpectedly touching
final sequence
finally and inevitably we have dark
souls 2 the champion series of badass
bosses whose lives are dedicated to
messing you up and they do repeatedly
there are loads of worthy adversaries in
the souls series and dark souls 2
delivered some awesome ones the pursuer
who you may be incredibly unlucky to
encounter early on does his very best to
chop you up into tiny little pieces with
his adept sword and shield skills the
incredibly unfair ruined sentinels will
have you throwing your controller across
the room if you don't bring along some
friends and then there's the smelter
demon for a lot of people he's the worst
of the lot with devastating and quick
blows from his flaming sword one of the
very coolest though has to be the
executioner's chariot a roaring
horse-drawn chariot that tries to bowl
you over your only respite from the
red-eyed shadow horses are to hide in
small alcoves until you can work out
what to do as with everything in dark
souls you can't hide forever
that is it for my picks be sure to let
me know which video game battle of 2014
was your favorite and i'll catch you
again next week